what is my most controversial video fish
lasagna bridge ah ah nope
it's why I don't like Marvel movies
let's let's look at this video this is
the worst dislike ratio I have on any
but not least an infinitely more
apparently a big deal of the movies that
a lot of superheroes die but I'm not
gonna spoiler which once or anything
like that but let's just entertain the
idea that lets say I remind dies let's
say Iron Man dies from Oliver write that
down
how good yeah I like how my main
criticism of the Marvel filmed was that
no one actually dies I was proven wrong
to be honest I never watched endgame or
any of the last films and and when I
flew recently from Japan to UK my
computer were in charge I had no choice
but to watch what was offered and it was
all Avengers of course and which is one
of the reasons I didn't like Marvel
because it's literally everywhere
ironically but I watched it and I
actually enjoyed it for the first time
please don't dislike this video
I love Marvel ok this is not the point
and I realized the reason why I liked it
so much was because I finally like one
of its heroes Thanos
that's right Thanos is epic and also
very sexy I realize that there's already
a hundred videos at least about the
philosophy of Banias and why was Stannis
right hmm Appalachian Pete well I would
argue that Thanos was actually better
than all of us here's why well first of
all what Stan is right to understand
that you must understand what is right
if you have glasses on now what is right
think about it why it's such a smug
question don't think too hard this is
not I'm 14 and this is D I'm waiting
right is in most senses and you could
call an ethical system to bring wellness
to something a community or yourself and
sometimes making the right choice will
lead to unethical actions like say
wiping off half the universe the
philosopher søren kierkegaard who I've
spoken about before on my channel calls
this concept in the book of fear and
trembling the theological suspension of
the ethical tlo's means goal in in greek
and it's basically means putting aside
what is right or what is technically
good to do in hope for something greater
if you buy G fuel enter code pity PI to
become ethically energized and and
thirst quench you made a theological
decision Thanos believed that wiping out
half the universe would be would make it
so that life would actually be able to
continue and thrive and become better
and did not just cease to exist I think
that's the consensus I don't really
remember this universe
I annoyed its resources finite his life
is left unchecked life who ceased to
exist it needs you don't know that I'm
the only one who knows that but his goal
is for things to turn out well and he
doesn't take pleasure in the killing
which i think is an important
distinction of him being good or right
[Music]
and that's the important distinction of
why he's likable he's a tragic hero
this makes Tanis what søren kierkegaard
would call a night of infinite
resignation and so what is that then
well Kierkegaard defined life in three
different stages and I spoken about this
in my channel before but the first one
where most of us is is in the aesthetic
we're sort of trapped here we're
focusing purely on our senses we try and
maximize we try and maximize them as
much as possible to feel as good as
possible
we don't live for one single thinking
but many many different things and I
think most people can relate to that we
think these choices based on what will
make us happy so how do you get out of
the aesthetic well you move on to the
ethical and to put it very simple it's
basically living for others or another
purpose beyond your senses and it's here
where the night of internet resignation
can exist just because it's called a
night doesn't mean it has to be a man it
could be any but I also believe
character garda calls it a night to
symbolize someone very strong and
chivalrous and tough you would have to
be to make these sort of decisions that
a knight of infinite resignation has to
make when character God talks about the
infinite he's talking about what you
love and that is what defines your
entire worldview it quote from the book
is so for the first thing the night will
have power to concentrate the whole
content of life and the whole
significance of reality in one single
wish the night of infinite resignation
resigns just that everything for this
wish and Diana's did this he put he put
everything aside to reach this goal to
reach this wish a hero is typically
defined by what they love
what do you love have you ever made a
decision on something that you sacrifice
for the greater good
maybe you've given up on a dream to
pursue happiness for someone else by
understanding what we love we open up
ourselves to become more vulnerable and
this is something that's very hard to do
but a night of infinite resignation also
understands that the world is finite the
world doesn't always fall into the right
place sometime
you will not always win there's a limit
to each and every one of our capacities
and no matter how hard we try let's say
you have all these mean superheroes who
manages to frickin turn back time to
stop you Jesus
time travel what
I see this is an absolute win say they
didn't snap Thanos back sorry spoilers
would Thanos given up giving up at this
point
I don't think so and this is what Jackie
God calls for when you reach your your
capacity of your limit you must then
turn inward and here you can keep your
love he says as as young as the day you
had it and and it lives on spiritually
infinite this of course would be very
painful but you can reconcile in its
spiritually infinite existence I think
it's really interesting with character I
said he himself gave up his love omit
him his life Regine Olsen to pursue his
writing at another sacrifice and I think
that's probably why he came up with this
whole theory idea but that I think
that's what makes him so interesting
because he truly lived his ideas I
criticize character guard in a previous
video because he explained everything
previously in this book either-or with
such perfect rationale for hundreds of
pages and when he talks about the
aesthetic and when he talks about the
ethic but when he talked about the
third-stage the religion rationale was
just completely thrown out the window
and and to me whenever discussing
religion it has always just seemed to me
like blind acceptance and blind
following and it seemed like he wanted
you to do the same thing but it's clear
that I didn't understand character guard
because that's not what he wanted at all
if anything he was strongly against that
he was strongly against blinded
acceptance it's part of the reason why
he criticized Christianity at the time
because people had just accepted
becoming Christians and it wasn't
something that he thought people
actually practiced even if you're not
religious you still probably blindly
accept a lot of ideas that's not to say
that everyone religious blindly accept
ideas but you understand what I mean we
protect ourselves from ideas because
because some of them would change our
worldview if we accepted them some ideas
will never fully get pondered and
therefore we will never find our
infinite is it a coincidence that is
called Marvel infinity war I don't think
so
this whole connection with Marvel is so
cringy but I tricked you into watch a
listening philosophy epically
you know my final message is this and
it's the same as character cards you
have to practice your ideas you can't
just buy a ninja sky into how to become
a pro gamer and then become a pro gamer
you must practice I'm 14 and this is
PewDiePie I hope you guys enjoyed this
video it's a bit random I understand
I really enjoyed character gods fear and
trembling it's a great book I kind of
feel like I've jumped a bit back and
forth too much with philosophies so but
it's something that I enjoy reading and
something I enjoy sharing so I hope you
guys enjoy it as well
I made a tea illogical sacrifice for you
to hopefully enjoy this video because
it's not gonna get any beer system by
the figurine
bye-bye
you